all right so today's topic someone sent
us this dog related story so we're going
to pop it open
shout out to phil defranco i couldn't be
bothered to splice this whole thing
together so i'm just going to watch his
video on it and the first thing we're
going to talk about today is this
brookhout situation that we're seeing on
youtube right now if you're unfamiliar
she's this kind of a smaller
slash medium-sized youtuber historically
it looks like she has a variety of
content but recently there's a lot of
videos about her doberman and she
recently posted a video that was simply
titled plastic wrap prank on my doberman
and she puts up plastic wrap and she's
playing with the dog but the dog you
know kind of keeps out smarting her and
is going under the plastic wrap and
seemingly it's kind of this whatever
video but it appears that there was
actually much more to the story there
was another video uploaded on the fifth
title leaked video of youtuber brick
house hitting her dog and just based off
of the outfit it appears to be from that
same video and based on a comment from
the uploader they wrote the person who
sent me this said that she accidentally
uploaded it and they quickly recorded it
and adding when they refreshed the page
it was the edited version not showing
this near the beginning of this video we
see the dog kind of jump up
this happens they then come back into
frame
brooke then tries to continue the video
the dog seems excited wants to play and
then this happens
stop
okay uh listen i don't know [ __ ] about
dog but i'm pretty sure
spitting on a dog is in no way
productive in terms of making it correct
its behavior
i could be wrong preach you know more
about dogs so i'll let you go
okay first and foremost see what's
happening here is that the dog
is playing you wanted to play with the
dog you started with by playing with the
dog and stuff like that
now you're gonna move switch on him that
makes no sense the dog is still playing
because you were playing with him
plastic wrapper prank on my dog dog is
playing doesn't know what's going on
you didn't get what you expected from
the dog is just like okay we're playing
so i want to go there i have to go there
i have to go there what's next what's
next
dog is excited you got the dog excited
now the dog is still excited you want
him to stop
well this is not going to happen and the
dog didn't do anything really wrong
he was just there you snap you snap at
the dog so the dog is not going to
understand what you're doing so yes
you're clearly being abusive over here
a lot of people justify this behavior by
saying the dog needs this kind of
training no [ __ ] you just are lazy and
aren't effective
at being a good parent and being a good
trainer therefore you're
resulting into the lowest barometer of
parenting you can think of which the
worst part is that that dog is gonna
eventually grow and be
bigger and at some point you're gonna do
some [ __ ] like that he's gonna snap at
you
and your [ __ ] ass gonna be like oh my
god my dog bit me
probably not i can't believe probably
not you know what probably you know what
it's probably going to snap at somebody
else
and that's even more dangerous because
people who are very abusive with their
dogs the dogs don't attack them they
attack strangers
i apologize to anyone who has been
affected negatively by the footage
regarding that footage she says on the
day in particular that the video was
filmed and actually this past week
things in my outside life have been less
than exceptional i am not going to play
the victim card or anything of that sort
but i do want to point out that i am
rarely as upset as what was shown in the
footage
you can't say i don't want to play the
victim card
and then the sentence before you just
said hey
my the fact that my life was less than
exceptional was a huge contributing
factor
to why i was abusive to somebody else so
because life was shitty at you
you thought it justifies you being
shitty at somebody else you're playing
the victim
the bubbly happy go lucky brook that you
often see in my videos is typically an
accurate representation of me but it's
obvious that i'm playing up my mood in
this video when i'm clearly actually
frustrated an accurate representation of
you listen
an accurate representation of you is who
you are when the cameras aren't rolling
or when you think they're not rolling so
that
you are that was an accurate
representation of you i'm not saying
it's necessarily the only accurate
but it's probably a very real side of
you that's part of you
because let me tell you this what do you
mean we preach talk on camera
find us in these streets we talk the
exact same way we keep these energies
and all the time
we do that's what we do like like it's
still this look at this
track whenever we [ __ ] up we [ __ ] up
whenever we mess up
we do mess up when we do mess up in real
life you understand what i stutter when
i mess up some words that's what i do in
real life
it is an accurate representation of you
it's not whenever you want to show
it that is acting oh now i'm just my
good side my good angle and everything
and stuff
that is good no boo boo all the time
this [ __ ] is part of you
i thought you'd be i thought your
behavior was problematic but this
apology is turning out to be more of a
problem
and i hate the word problematic but it
is problematic
then going on to say this does not
justify me yelling at my dog in the way
that i did and i am fully aware of that
saying she shouldn't have gotten as
angry she shouldn't have raised her
voice and yelled at him then adding
however when my 75 pound doberman is
jumping up in my face with his mouth
open i do as a dog parent
have to show him that this behavior is
unacceptable you see that last sentence
right there that sentence right there
it's how she really feels about the
situation everything before that is just
[ __ ] yeah everything before that is
just nonsense
actually she really feels like her
actions were justified and if there was
no social media outrage she would never
say that there was anything wrong with
anything everything before was the plate
of gold that she's sitting this whatever
the hell she did
she said last at on that's what it was
but i want to make it known regardless
of what my dog does i should not have
acted that way towards him she goes on
to say that she is not a dog abuser or
animal abuser in any way shape or form
well we witnessed your piece of dog
yes you are you are you're not you're
not
an abuser of many dogs but your dog you
treat them you treat your dog like that
okay that makes you an abuser
and then she says yes i did that and
that that was not the way i should have
handled the situation did i spit on my
dog
no you made the gesture [ __ ] same [ __ ]
same [ __ ] same [ __ ] that's like saying i
did i spit on my dog no i spat beside
him
it's the same [ __ ] i didn't shoot at you
i sit next to your head
what because some people went through
her archive and found when she said
things like this dogs do not respond
well to punishment training where
there's like a punishment
or a backlash for not doing the right
thing
you [ __ ] up
yeah that'll show you not to put all
your [ __ ] on on the social media
now you just look dumb you do you do
look like a liar right now
you look like a liar you look like
you're inconsistent you look like you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
you look like basically who you are
yeah oh what's up who is she you [ __ ]
up whatever the [ __ ] i said
uh i'm not that bad of a person i'm not
a yes you are boo boo
you know what i was just yes you are you
know i wish people were just right i
wish they were just right i [ __ ] up i
[ __ ] up have a good day
i wish that's all they would write and
then they'd be great but instead they
got to give all this nonsensical context
man listen that's what happens when
people put nonsensical [ __ ] on the
internet and they're like i'm just gonna
document every aspect of my life [ __ ]
if you're a shitty person
then you might accidentally document
shitty aspects of your own life which
you need yeah it's like [ __ ]
who vlog all the time
and then they get caught and they're
like oh this is what i'm doing in japan
but they're just running around making
fun of the locals
yeah and then it turns out to be
international yeah because i'm not like
that
yes [ __ ] weed you're not sorry for what
happened
[ __ ] you sorry you got caught uh all in
all that's pretty much all i got for
this if you are someone who creates
content online please don't put
every aspect of your life online okay
first
don't give a [ __ ] and then you're gonna
shoot yourself in the foot
people are so busy clout chasing they
don't even realize
how did you upload that video yourself
how dumb do you have to be
yeah that [ __ ] was up for like 20
minutes and some of the people like
gotcha goddamn people are dumb as rocks
oh man leave your comments below we want
to know what you guys think do you guys
think that was really excessive if so
let us know which how you train your
dogs effectively
and if you have the number to caesar the
dog trainer or dog whisperer
just leave it in the comments so we can
link it to her
yo man what the hell is wrong with you
when i saw the spit i was like the dog
don't understand that that's not
you just need to get some [ __ ] out there
right
it's just like it's as effective as me
going to the dog and being like
hey
[Music]